est-ce que vous saviez vous pour pour
que Tati Daniel était mariée avec son
mari s'appelait tonton Noël je l'ai pas
ce truc de fou là alors que Marion
Bartoli demande à Noël le Great il a des
nouvelles de Zinédine Zidane dont le nom
circulé depuis plusieurs mois pour
éventuellement succéder à Didier
Deschamps celui-ci dérape complètement
envisagé de se séparer de
vous joindre là ces derniers jours non
Zinédine Zidane
pour qu'il trouve un club des mots et
une prise de position qui provoque
immédiatement un Taulé Zidane c'est la
France explique dans un tweet qui vient
de Mbappé on ne manque pas de respect à
la légende écrit l'attaquant vedette des
Bleus Franck Ribéry lui emboîte le pas à
plan le patron de la fédération
française a consulté rapidement un psy
je s'imaginer bien évidemment c'est
quand même le bordel ces émissions qui
sont en direct après l'apéro quoi
je trouve que ça c'est quand même un peu
enfin c'est ce qui nous sont vos grandes
gueules c'est que nous on est avant
l'apéro quoi une embardée
son niveau d'alcoolémie ou pas j'en sais
rien des rumeurs sur Noël le grec en fin
de journée parfois je dirais il n'a pas
vu que de l'eau minérale bonjour C'est
Zinédine Zidane voulait bien me prendre
au téléphone ou pas bah avec grand
plaisir puisqu'on attend toujours la
réaction d'ailleurs de vie des Zidane
qui pour l'instant
moi je pense que j'ai mis deux buts en
finale de la Coupe du monde alors au
camembert comme Aurélie Jean-Pierre
Papin il a donné la victoire de la
finale de la Coupe du Monde 98 à
l'équipe de France sans lui aurait pas
bien sûr première étoile sur le maillot
qu'est-ce qu'il a fait 4 ans après hein
et et il a il a coûté un coup de bulle
[Musique]
[Rires]
le président de la République il est
comme les Français il est vraiment déçu
et vraiment heurté quand de tels
légendes du sport français du sport
mondial sont tenus dans 20 ans dans 30
ans lorsque la mort aura ramassé les
copies le nom de Noël le Great
disparaîtra quand celui de Zinedine
Zidane brillera toujours au fronton de
l'Arc de triomphe des excuses de la part
de Noël le grec qui finissent par tomber
ce matin alors que les réactions se
multiplient et que la presse juge les
propos sur Zinédine Zidane inacceptables
je tiens à présenter mes excuses pour
ses propos qui ne reflètent absolument
pas ma pensée ni ma considération pour
le joueur qu'il était et l'entraîneur
qu'il est devenu
vous avez parlé de l'alcool pour
Monsieur le grec mais moi je pense que
moi je pense tout simplement que ce
monsieur comme beaucoup
d'ample
ment Zidane et qui parle de Didier
Deschamps comme un de ses enfants comme
son auxiliaire de vie mais pas comme un
patron avec son employeur le patron a
toujours du mal à s'habituer à sa
prothèse dentaire
donc forcément ça me gêne j'ai peur que
ça tombe et forcément je vais faire des
baskets
[Musique]
à part ça à Tokyo le rituel d'endurance
de l'eau glacée un petit bain dans une
cuve ou deux blocs de glace de 135 kg
ont fondu ou pas on fait comme ça la
bonne année mais surtout la santé et ça
fait 68 ans ça dure cette affaire de la
glace
non il n'est jamais trop tard pour
adresser ses vœux lui l'a fait
aujourd'hui et ce sont de loin les plus
pêchu et les plus inspirés
je présente tous mes vœux de bonnes
meilleures années
dites-moi c'est lui qui avait dit la
vieillesse est un naufrage
c'était de Gaulle il parlait de Pétain à
l'époque
la liste malheureusement nous avons
terminé
donc
ce sont des dents
le patron manque de tout dévoiler face à
Muriel la responsable des achats il
préfère prendre la fuite
si vous ne savez pas comment vous
habiller pour aller au travail ce matin
oui c'est une solution mais aussi la
solution des Londoniens regardez comment
ils se sont habillés hier dans le métro
je découvrirai les images
et c'est pas le froid qui les a
découragé faisait 6 degrés alors c'est
un concept qui est assez simple Pas de
pantalon dans le métro phénomène né à
New York aux États-Unis à 20 ans
enchanté
quoi par original des attributs qui font
que j'ai du mal à le regarder dans les
yeux etc
va mettre ça c'est à toi oui oui tu vas
montrer à papa
[Musique]
c'est le roi des animaux
comme ça il va capturer les souris
ok les chiens sont-ils plus heureux à
bord d'une voiture thermique
non malheureusement ils ont refusé de
répondre on a donc mené un test avec une
vingtaine de chiens un trajet à bord
d'une voiture thermique puis le même
trajet dans une électrique à chaque fois
on a mesuré leur rythme cardiaque
observer leur comportement résultat les
chiens sont bien plus apaisés à bord
d'une électrique leur rythme cardiaque
et 30% plus faibles
[Musique]
arise totalement de cette action Léo le
Roi Lion
on va chercher les souris c'est toi le
plus fort
entrez
pas grand chose à part le chanteur là
comment s'appelle la